imagine giving birth to a 24 pound baby
that's three times the size of an
average human newborn ouch
but for Kiwi birds giant chicks are the
norm
females lay a single egg up to 20% of
their body weight yet when you check out
other extreme births in the animal
kingdom the key we can consider itself
lucky shingle back lizards also have a
tough pregnancy these reptiles usually
have one to two babies at a time which
doesn't sound so bad until you realize
that combined the babies make up 1/3 of
the mother's body weight that's like a
human giving birth to a 7 year old but a
baby doesn't need to be big to be
difficult take the porcupine those sharp
spines protect it from predators but
they're sometimes not so fun for Mom
you see baby porcupines called poor
Cupid's aren't hairless like most rodent
newborns these guys are born fully
quilled normally this isn't a problem
for Mom since the quills are soft at
birth and gradually harden over the next
few hours but complications can arise
when the poor cue pets are facing the
wrong direction because their quills can
get caught in the birth canal on the way
out speaking of birth canals the spotted
hyena has an interesting one females
have phallic like genitalia the
scientific term for this is pseudo penis
and they give birth out of this pseudo
penis which will sometimes rip apart in
the process it's not only painful it can
be lethal in fact about 15% of
first-time mothers die giving birth
but believe it or not a species of
velvet spider has it even worse you know
how some animals chew up food for their
babies well stego typhus lineatus
takes this to a whole new level right
after she lays an egg sac the mother's
tissues start to degrade
once the spiderlings hatch she
regurgitates her own liquefied insides
and the babies chow down nine days later
they suck up the last of her fluids and
strike out on their own leaving nothing
but an empty husk thanks mom but
childbirth isn't just dangerous or
uncomfortable for mothers with some
animals the baby has it pretty rough
take the Tasmanian Devil the mom gives
birth to up to fifty Joey's at a time
each the size of a raisin they have to
crawl from the mother's birth canal over
her body and into her pouch where
they'll snuggle up for another four
months but there's a catch mom has only
four nipples in her pouch so right from
birth the Joey's are literally on a mad
dash for their lives and only the
strongest four will make it talk about
sibling rivalry huh overall one thing is
clear humans aren't the only ones who
have it rough when it comes to giving
birth what's the craziest animal fact
you know tell us in the comments and
thanks for watching